hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast modification of glycans
and file processing presented by Ryan
Boniface a cell biology scientist level
3 at bio production research and
development Thermo Fisher Scientific I'm
Cindy Valdez and I will be your
moderator for this educational webcast
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
get Co part of thermo Fisher Scientific
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click on the green Q&A button located at
the lower left of your presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on the screen we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing this
presentation via a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right or use
the Q&A button to let us know that
you're having problems please join me
now in welcoming the scientist Ryan
Boniface I will now turn the
presentation over to him welcome sir
thanks Susie so hello everybody I guess
depending on where you are in the world
good morning good evening good afternoon
good night so I'm going to speak a
little bit about modification of glycans
in bio processing and I guess I'll get
started by saying that I've I've been a
scientist now for for ten years with
with thermo Fisher and I think it's it's
it's pretty interesting the way our
industry has advanced over the last 10
years when I started here there was a
lot of times where we were we were
performing cell culture experiments and
our goal was to get as much growth as
possible you know we were working with
cell lines that didn't have necessarily
a lot of productivity
and then over time we started shifting
our focus to try to get as much out of
the cells as possible so we started
turning towards looking at specific
productivity how much how much protein
could we get these cells to make so
really we went from having less than a
gram per liter so now we've got anywhere
from 2 grams per liter all the way maybe
up to 10 grams per liter so quite an
advancement and I would say over the
last four or five years you know the
focus has started to shift now where be
the proteins they're the cells are there
but the quality maybe isn't and we're
really starting to really dive into that
quality aspect of it because it's really
important and and we really all need to
kind of think about the quality that
we're producing from our proteins and
you know it's I tend to think of it and
I always have for a long time that you
know I have customers that I have to
develop media for and and feeds and
supplements so I can help them with with
quality so I tend to think of customers
as anybody out there that that's
producing drugs and proteins and
immunoglobulins but the fact is we're
we're kind of all really customers right
I mean there's a chance that there are
going to be drugs that are being made
that you or I might be using our loved
ones our family members parents children
grandparents so really we really kind of
need to have a great deal of vested
interest into this we need to make sure
that we're producing high quality
products because ultimately we're all
going to be customers we're all going to
be affected by this and I've kind of
said multiple times when talking about
this is that you know it's one thing if
you can produce the protein but it's not
going to matter if you can't get the
quality if it's not where it needs to be
if you're not targeting the right thing
and if it's not right you know it could
have detrimental effects to anybody
taking the
so they could elicit immune reactions
and things like that or maybe not be as
effective as it could be so really you
know as somebody that works for Thermo
Fisher Scientific we're incredibly
focused on us we're very passionate
about making sure that our customers and
everybody can have the protein quality
that they want that they're targeting
and this really fits with our mission
statement which is to enable our
customers to make the world healthier
cleaner and safer and you know going
through this we we know that that
therapeutic protein quality is really
important to everybody it's important to
all of our customers and we also know
that you know everybody's looking to
reduce costs and increase productivity
and again like I've stated glycosylated
protein quality significantly impacts
the quality the consistency the efficacy
of anything that you're producing so
really our challenge is to be able to
identify these glycans measure them and
really control glycoproteins so I'm not
going to get incredibly in-depth with
glycosylated
but you can see here on this slide slide
number three that these are some of the
the kind of more typical glycol forms
that we're looking at
we've got terminal galactose terminal
cellulation few coasts nanostructures
and these are all important for the
effects that they can have on the drug
you can see in the case of galactose
increasing that would increase the CDC
immune response you know an increasing
terminal glick neck you can have longer
serum half-life's increase EDC seeing so
all these things are really important
now certainly this is just a very small
subset of glycans that you could
actually be looking at there's thousands
of different combinations but at least
for a lot of our industry we're kind of
focused on on some of the ones that I'm
showing here certainly G 0 G 1 G 2 and a
few cos elated versions of that as well
as having a sigh lated glyco form so
there's plenty of applications for
glycosylated not every customer is going
to be the same
certainly everybody's going to be
looking at different things and we're
going to have customers that are
certainly they've got a cell line and
maybe they're going to be transitioning
to a new clone or a different cell line
and they need to match the glycosylation
so that's something that there's a
particular customer set that that we'd
be looking to to help another one would
be biosimilars so a biosimilar is going
to be producing a drug and they have to
match the glycan profile of an innovator
molecule so there's something where it's
really important to target a very
specific glidecam profile and then you
can have another category where you can
you know improving the efficacy of a
molecule so this is getting the best
glycosylation profile you can to
increase stability improve the
pharmacokinetics and dynamics of a
molecule and this goes for innovators
who are looking to have the best drug
possible but then another category which
we don't talk about all that often are
like the biosimilars the bio betters so
these companies that are looking to
produce maybe a generic drug a
biosimilar but they know that they can
improve the product quality enough where
it is technically you know a new drug
but it is vastly improved kinetics so
they're just some of the applications
that we might be looking into
so I'm going to turn in and kind of talk
about glycans and and their profiles and
cell culture so when we're looking at
cell culture there's there's a number of
aspects that that go into controlling
like oscillation or what can can affect
it and I've always kind of looked at
this as kind of having two categories
one being the cell culture process and
the other one being like your media
components your supplements your feeds
but really it's a little bit more
complicated than that certainly you have
your cell line which is one aspect
different clones different cell lines
whether you have a chose a line or maybe
a two nine three cell they're going to
have very different like camp profiles
so that's one aspect kind of choosing a
clone the other one would be kind of
what system you're using to grow your
cells through the ruse protein there
going to be plenty of differences
between flasks by reactors perfusion
setups and then you know you do have
your call your process parameters your
things like your pH your do your your
co2 temperature mixing rates shear those
things will certainly have an effect
like oscillation and again that other
category would be your media your
supplements what kind of components
you're giving to your cells what kind of
building blocks they have to build these
glycan patterns or these structures and
when looking at this we know that that
do is important if you can maintain your
do between let's say ten and a hundred
percent you can you can kind of ensure
that you're going to get consistent like
oscillations
certainly if you increase your co2
there's a chance that you can decrease I
elation lower temperatures can decrease
silac acid but at the same time
performing temp shifts can result in
maybe maintaining like oscillation along
with probably increasing and/or
maintaining specific productivity I
spoke a little bit about differences
between different types of cell culture
when you're comparing perfusion to
fed-batch cultures there is a chance
that if using a perfusion culture you
could be increasing your citation on
your on your protein and then also
something like your metabolites and in
the case of ammonia that can be very
preventative to getting terminal
glycosylation most of the things that
i'm showing here on this slide these are
all available or widely available in
literature and to kind of show some
examples of this here on the slide is
demonstrating what can happen if you do
have a sort of increased ammonia
concentration and so what we have here
is we have on the left condition number
one you can see there's a high peak for
G zero sorry about 87% in that case I
you look on the bottom the ammonia
concentration on that day day 14 was
about nine millimolar if you look all
the way over at the right condition 3
again day 14 but this time the ammonia
concentration is about is half four
point five normal ER and you can see
that there's a decrease in G's are off
by about maybe 10 to 12 percent and you
also have an increase in g1 up and maybe
a slight increase in G to F and this
would be pretty important for for
customers and harvest and maintaining
the the level of ammonia that's present
in your culture so obviously having
higher galactose alation G 1 F G to F is
important
and and obviously minimizing the amount
of ammonia buildup in your culture is
also very important as another example
harvest viability you know I know that
more often than not we want to extend
our cultures as long as possible to get
the most out of the cells but it's also
important to harvest the cells at a
point where they're they're sort of in a
good viability range so in the left you
can see there's a day 14 harvest and the
cells are 95% viability and again g0f
the peak is about 70 72 % about 20% g1f
and if you look on the right day 19 now
we've got a 45 percent viability you can
see that g0 has gone up and terminal
galactose elation G went up G to F has
gone down so this is a this is a
situation where this wouldn't be that
very ideal at the same time as your
cells are dying in your viability is
decreasing you also have a lot of cell
lysis and death which is going to
release plenty of proteases that can
also degrade your protein and your
glycans
so early on when we were looking to
develop a a glycan tuning product I
screamed
handfuls of components that that you
know through literature other means
should have some impact on glycosylation
and when looking through these
components
I found a handful that were were
functional so if we look at this graph
here to the left if you look at the very
left most peak listed as efficient feed
c+ control you can see there's a very
high level of g0f almost ninety percent
and subsequently you have very small
percentages of g1f ng to us and then if
you look all the way over to the right
it's listed as 1x you can see that
there's a drastic decrease in g0f so in
that case I found a handful of
components that I know worked and my
first thought process is let's add them
to the media let's see how it changes
the culture so I added them in at what I
deemed is a 1x concentration and luckily
enough everything worked out and I was
able to get a sharp decrease in g0 I
went down from about 90% all the way
down to almost 45% and you can see that
G 1 F increased quite a bit ng to have
increased quite a bit so these
components are working that's great this
is exactly what I was looking for so
knowing that I can put them in at a high
concentration knowing that that works my
next thought process is well that's
great for somebody that's looking to
just maximize the amount of
glycosylation that they have well what
about those biosimilars that are out
there that are looking to target a very
specific profile or the customers that
are changing between cell lines we need
to
you know hit an exact glidecam profile
so in that case knowing that these
components work my first thought process
was let's titrate them back into the
culture let's add them in there at
different concentrations and see if we
can get predictable glycan profiles and
as I did this you can see that if we
move from just the on the left the
efficient beats e+ control to the very
small amount of 0.03 X there's about a
30% decrease in g0l and then as you move
further along you can see that there
were very small decreases in G's or F
maybe five at most 10% and although this
looks alright
it wasn't a linear response okay and you
can see just by adding that point 0 3 X
concentration that's a pretty small
margin of error and what we're finding
was that there really wasn't a lot of
consistency in this fact effect from
from experiment to experiment and when
I'm looking to develop a product I have
to develop something that's going to be
easy enough for our customers to use it
doesn't do any good for me to release a
product that I hand over and when I get
the question how do I use this how much
should I add in this case it's kind of I
don't know you know I can't tell you
exactly how much to add and it kind of
introduces a trial and error scenario so
you might perform an experiment you
might titrate these components in and
say ok it's you know it's it's maybe
around 0.36 X but it's not it's not what
you need to be so then you have to have
a second experiment and maybe that
second experiment doesn't get you to
where you need so then you have a third
experiment and so on so really
and looking to reduce the amount of
experiments that anybody would have to
perform to get to target a specific like
in profile it doesn't do me any good and
it doesn't do our customers any good
service a product that that isn't easy
to use that requires multiple Trier with
child's and a lot of effort and a lot of
you know time and money on these
experiments so what we did is we abandon
that approach just try to tie trading in
those components just wasn't working so
well what we came up with is this what
we're calling transition points and I
kind of walk through this slide so that
it makes sense and I'm going to show an
example on the next slide using this
exact same table so we have a series of
efficient feed plus products there's an
A plus a B+ and a c-plus at the same
time we developed the glycan tune +
products there's an A plus and a B+ and
a c-plus and each one of those a pluses
and B pluses and C pluses match up to
each other from efficiency perspective
and AG like an tune perspective so let's
say for this example here we'll be using
efficient feed C+ and gly canteen c-plus
and this experiment what we have is
daily feeding from days for through 15
and the very top condition or we just
see it says efficient feed plus what we
would have is daily feeding with just
the efficient feed plus product for this
example we'll just say efficient feed
c-plus
so every day from day for through 15
with feeding just efficient feed c-plus
and then if we look further down here on
the very bottom we have the glidecam
tune + condition so in this case we're
feeding the cultures a separate
condition with nothing but glycan tune c
+ from days for through 15
and then what we have in the middle
we're deeming as transition points so
let's take day eleven that condition for
instance what you would do is you would
start feeding efficient feed c-plus on
day four and feed that all the way up to
day 10 and then on day 11
you completely switch to glycan tune
c-plus and from day 11 through day 15
you're only feeding like an tune c-plus
and obviously the other conditions here
are just moving that transition point
around so you're just changing the day
that you're switching from the efficient
feed product to the glycan tune product
so in the case of day nine instead of
switching over in day eleven you're just
switching over on day nine show an
example of what this looks like with
efficient feed c-plus and glycogen
c-plus here we have some data and what
you can see and the very last again like
that first experiment we have just
efficient feed c+ control and the very
right you have just the glycan tune c+
control and I should state which I
didn't mention me for our glycan to NC
plus is a complete feed so as everything
that you need to to to add back to your
culture to keep yourselves going with
the addition of glycosylation enhancing
components and now what you can see is
that we get a much more linear response
by doing these transition points rather
than the previous approach where we were
titrating in components so now you have
this stepwise approach where you get
more predictable and linear responses in
your glide cam profiles and for this
experiment i was only showing odd days
but certainly like if we take
day 15 and day 13 those transition
points you can see that we've got maybe
70% cheeser off or day 15 and maybe 65%
for day 13 but if you were to transition
on day 14 you could more than likely
have a result that maybe fell in
somewhere in between that so maybe about
67 68 percent so there's numerous ways
to do this and I'm sure that you could
take this even further and you could
have this timed by the hour to get a
very specific profile so what this
really eliminated was a lot of the
guessing work with volumes through scale
up and other things like that where now
you're just picking a day to transition
to a the gly Canton feed so this next
slide be the graph up in the top right
is the data that I just showed you and
on the left this is to show that that we
can modify these glycans using this
transition approach without really
negative affecting the growth or
productivity of the cell line I think we
had variation summer within about 10%
so this is an example on this slide
using efficient PC plus with gly Canton
c-plus on this next slide here is data
for using efficient PV plus look like an
ting P plus and again on the top right
you can see that stepwise pattern same
transition days as efficient beat C+ and
glycan tenancy plus you get a nice
linear response and a predictable
response and on the left with the
exception of that one data point which
has some fairly large error bar you can
see that both growth on the top five
will cell density on the bottom AGG
tighter very similar results even though
we have dramatic changes in the glycan
profile
and this next slide here's an example
using the efficiency de plus products
with glycan tune a plus again the top
right you can see the effects on the
glidecam profiles using these
transitions and the left again top top
graph you have the viable cell densities
and on the bottom IgG titers
so there's going to be plenty of
instances where a a customer or anybody
for that matter is they're going to have
maybe a media and feed combination that
they really like but they're not getting
the glycan profiles or the performance
that they really want and so they might
want to try the glycan tune products
with their current media and feed setup
and that's okay
in this experiment we're using a
commercially available feed with a
commercial commercially available media
that is corresponding to that that that
media and we're using this this
particular medium feed to the
manufacturers specified feeding profiles
and what we have here is again
transition points so for this particular
feed the feeding days were feeding on
day 5 day 7 day 9 and day 11 so what you
have on the very left side the left
graph or the last set of bars with G 0
about 75% that's just this commercially
available media and feet with no glycan
tune and then on the very right is the
commercial media said with glycan tuned
on days 5 7 9 11 so you can see a
decrease in in G 0 F from let's say 75
percent down to looks like maybe 47 48
percent and then the other days we did
transition points again so a 7 and a 5
we fed with the commercially available
feed and then on day 7 9 and 11 we fed
gleich hinton c+ for the next set of
bars we fed day 9 and day 11 with gly
Canton and the last set we fed just 8 11
so days 5
9 were fed with the commercial feed and
we only fed and with glycan 2 and day 11
so you can see that you might have a
feeding profile you might have another
media you might have another feed but
it's still possible to use these glycan
tune products with your setup and you
can still do those transition points
even with feeding that isn't daily
feeding something that's that's bolus
feeding every other day
it's really show the the importance and
the power behind these transition points
in the glycan tune products what I have
here on this slide and and and this is
this is this really illustrates just
just just how well this can actually
work if you look there are four
commercially relevant bio therapeutic
glycan profiles that we've measured
internally on this graph and using the
data from one of those previous
experiments using efficient feed C+ and
glycan 10 C+ with those transition
points that I talked about we were able
to pretty closely match the glycan
profiles of each one of these
commercially relevant bio therapeutic
role files you can see that we're only
with within maybe a couple percent of
the target profile so you know this is
really critical for those biosimilar
customers out there they know that
they've got to hit a profile they're
gonna try to hit it exactly dead-on as
much as possible I'm sure that there's
some wiggle room but they're going to
try to hit it with a hundred percent
accuracy so this is a chance for them to
get really close with a very simple
protocol and in this case to match these
profiles we had transitions on on day
nine day 15 again day 15 and then day 11
so another important aspect of these
products both the efficient p+ products
and the glycan ting plus products is
that they utilize our a GT technology so
because of this they're really easy to
reconstitute it is as simple as just
adding to water they auto pH
there's no unnecessary steps to Phe no
long mixing steps you literally add it
to your water you mix it you bring up to
a final volume you filter it and you're
ready to go and at the same time these
feeds are super concentrated so for the
efficient feed products and the glycan
tune products you can take them beyond a
1 X concentration so in the case of a
plus and B plus are both efficient feed
and glycan tune you can concentrate them
anywhere from 1x all the way up to 3x
and then for efficient feed C + +
glycogen C + you can concentrate those
products anywhere from 1 X all the way
up to 2 X and so in what we're calling
super concentrating taking these up -
those either 2x or 3x levels you can
gain efficiency with your bioreactor
which I'll show on the next slide and
then you can also get a higher yield you
can get more protein because your your
you're not diluting your culture as much
and then there's also a cumulative
effect that over time if you're using a
more concentrated feed you can get about
10 to 15% more yield just by using a
concentrated feed so what I mean by
maximizing the efficiency of your
bioreactor so if we take let's say a
traditional bioreactor and this left bar
over here what you have is let's say
that you are going to use a feed at 1x
and the protocol required feeding 30%
over a length of time
and if you have a hundred liter
bioreactor you know that you just can't
add a hundred liters of median feed you
have to account sorry a hundred liters
of media and cells you have to account
for how much feed you're going to be
adding so you know you're going to be
adding 30% feed you have to set aside
roughly 30 litres of your reactor just
for your feet alone so you're really
starting your culture at about 70 liters
if you are going to use let's say that
same feed you still have to do 30%
feeding but now you can concentrate that
up to a 3x so what that means now is now
you've got a feed that you no longer
need to use 30 litres of it it's three
times as concentrated so therefore you
only need two you can use three times
less so in that case you're only using
10 liters so in this middle example if
you were starting your reactor at 71 or
70 liters and now you've got 10 liters
on top of that that leaves you with a
working volume of space that's not being
utilized of about 20 litres so what
we're saying is when you start your
experiment now you no longer have to
start at 70 litres using a 30% feed you
can concentrate the feed and you can
start at a much higher volume to start
your your experiment so you're really
kind of maximizing that space in that
rack you're starting at a higher volume
you're adding the same amount of
nutrition to your bio actor but you
don't have to add as much of it in fact
in this example three times three times
less
I spoke a little bit earlier about the
simplicity in reconstitution and again
this is as simple is adding water you
can see at the top there's about six
steps to reconstitute by Canton and the
efficiency plus products you add water
you mix uq s you bring up your final
volume you mix it just for a little bit
longer you go ahead and filter it and
it's ready to use you can see with other
single part feeds there's the
opportunity to introduce a lot of error
and variability you might be adding
water adding your powder mixing then
performing a pH adjust mixing then
bringing back to neutral after you
solubilized particular components your
mixing again you're bringing up the
final volume your mixing again your
filtering and then you're ready to use
and for multi part feeds like you can
see in the bottom you can it even more
steps on to that so where this brings a
lot of error in in you know there's a
potential to overshoot your PHS in that
case if you're trying to bring it back
down then you're probably going to bring
your has moe out of spec more steps more
pa-ching
more additions you could potentially
have reconstitution errors you can go
over volume and dilute your components
there's always the aspect of the extreme
PHS so it's one thing when you're making
this on a bench and it's just one liter
but let's face it when you're in a
manufacturing environment we're going to
have reactors that are thousand liters
and up and when you're at those sizes
you're no longer using milliliter
quantities very small milliliter
quantities of acid or base now you're
using tens of liters maybe hundreds of
liters excuse me and for the for the
technicians that are working with this
that really prevents a safety hazard
really want to minimize any kind of
unsafe practices or hazardous conditions
for all of our workers I'm going to say
time you want to minimize any extreme
PHS with bioreactor control so certainly
if if the feed could only go in it's
something that wasn't neutral like the
efficient feed plus and the collecting
products can go in yet then you're
introducing pH variability within your
bioreactor and now your systems got a
compensate for that which is also going
to change the osmolarity and other
aspects of the culture and can
potentially shock the cells or or show
up later on and in both the glycans or
or productivity or viability so we
certainly offer the glycan two and
efficient feed plus products as catalog
offerings but there's a lot of customers
out there and a lot of people looking
for for custom things and we have the
tools to work with you certainly we have
the ability to customize any of the
packaging you might be looking for so
you might want to buy a catalog product
but maybe the packaging isn't what
you're looking for we can certainly work
in that regard on the other side we can
customize the products themselves to to
meet a customer's needs we can certainly
change modify those glycosylated module
and components to add more over less of
and then we also have a services group
as offerings to help a customer that
maybe has a media and feed that they
don't want to give up that they really
want to use that and they don't want to
maybe they don't want to use the glycan
tune products but they still want that
added advantage of those glycosylation
modulating components so in that case we
have a services group that can work with
you the customer to develop a media or
feed based on based on a current
formulation that you might have and
incorporate these technologies to help
target specific like and profiles so
this is this is a case study that we had
and in this in this case a customer
liked their formulation but they were
not getting the product
the product quality that they needed so
the goals were that we had to be able to
modify their formulation but still
maintain their tighter levels you know
what good is it if we can get the
glidecam profile that they have but now
they've got 50% less productivity and on
top of that they had four out of twelve
glycan parameters that were matching
their targets the remaining eight just
they weren't even close so we had a work
to to to make all of that acceptable for
them maintain that tighter and try to
match all those glycans so we've got a
process where we've got multiple rounds
of optimization where we're using excuse
me do e design of experiments and we
base it on both literature and in-house
knowledge from you know hundreds of
these experiments that have been
performed and this was all done through
hype throughput means we have Amber
systems that were you can multi excuse
me utilized multiple by reactors at the
same time to test lots of conditions and
then we can confirm this with the
customer to see if it's meeting their
needs and in this particular case study
it was a success nine out of the 12
parameters for glycan targets were hit
just about dead-on and the remaining
three were within 80 percent of what the
customer was desiring and overall the
customer found is very acceptable and
they were happy to move forward with
that customized formulation
so to recap there's a lot of advantages
for using the efficient p+ products
along with the glycan toon products with
glycan toon you're able to target your
black cam profiles showing that
transition process that I talked about
where you switch from either a feat of
your choice or an efficient view plus
product to glycan toon plus I
demonstrated that you're able to control
your glycans and you're able to decrease
GSR from about 90 percent down to 45
percent and I know I've seen seen
examples where you can get even lower
than that depending on on your setup you
can get down into decreasing G's or up
down to maybe 30% and then through
working with our customs group in our
services group there's the ability to
read reduce g0f even more we know that
we can take these components to higher
levels if desired that could like I said
maybe even reduce G's or up down into
the the 30% range maybe even lower and
also showed that using glycan toon
didn't detrimental e effect growth or
product titer they remained very similar
to the control conditions at the same
time there's also an efficient process
for these feeds again it's it's a simple
dial in process I wanted to make we
wanted to make a product that was easy
for a customer to use there was no
guesswork in it
you start with one feed you transition
to the glycan tune feed or if you're
just looking for the best
glycosylated results you can you feed
nothing but like an tune also show the
ability to reduce the feeding volumes
giving you more flexibility with your
bioreactors in that case you know you
can come you can what we call super
concentrate the feeds you can bring them
up to a 2x or 3x and at the
same time you can deliver more nutrients
I talked about that there is a
cumulative effect if you're using the
concentrated feeds at a 2x or 3x you
will see maybe a 10 to 15% benefit over
the length of your your experiment in
regards to product tighter and then if
you chose you could certainly at a 2x or
3x concentration maybe add even more of
that feed to your your bioreactor
without having to add a significant
amount of volume and then lastly
I spoke about the reduced risk so
because of the easy reconstitution just
adding it back to water mixing and then
filtering and getting ready to use you
memorize all those errors that you can
introduce with pa-ching multiple
pa-ching steps you're just adding water
and you're just adding the h ET and it's
ready to use
and then lastly both with the efficient
feed products efficiency plus products
and the glycan time plus products we do
have some ability to keep these products
stable at room temperature for up to 30
days so we've gotten questions before
where a customer wants to attach their
feed to a bioreactor
and they want to leave it protect it
from life on the bench maybe they don't
have the means to refrigerate that and
that's okay that the d speeds will
remain stable for 30 days
so I'd like to thank everybody that's on
the line for attending the webinar and
I'll turn it back to the moderator so
that we can take some questions thank
you so much Ryan for your informative
presentation and really important
research we will now start that live Q&A
portion of the webinar if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on that green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window type your questions into the box
that appears on the screen and click the
send button we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for today so
let's start with our first audience
question how do I choose which glide
continuing product to pick
so I got
there's a couple answers for that one
would be if you're ready using an
efficient P plus product and a plus a B
plus or a C+ then I would recommend
transitioning over to the corresponding
fly canteen plus product the a plus 2b
plus or the c plus if a customer is
using their own media and feed
combination I generally recommend
starting with glycan tunze plus and
seeing where that gets gets them
certainly they can go ahead and test all
three of the feeds it really depends on
the cell line the media and the process
that's involved but there's a chance
that one of those three feeds will match
up if that doesn't work then certainly
we can go the services and customer out
where we can go ahead and work with the
customer to try to get that to fit their
system as much as possible okay great
thank you I'm not sure if you answered
this one within that question but an
audience member would like to know can
they use glycan tune with their current
feed yep yep and you know I showed an
example of that in the the presentation
but again it's certainly a possibility
I've seen at work there's no reason why
that can't be done and an audience
member would like to know how do I match
a glutton tune glucan tune product with
a feed from another vendor
so uh it's a little bit of a trial and
error basis but not that much I would
say you know I might have sort of
answered this another question but I
would probably start with glycan tune C+
and try that with current feed and maybe
trying that at a a similar feed profile
at a similar concentration certainly you
don't have to go as far as concentrating
to a 2x or 3x these products certainly
work at a 1x concentration and you know
you can certainly use your your feed
profile that your you currently have set
up and then you can do a simplified
experiment where you take a couple
transition points excuse me and
transition to you know let's say you
know any one of the glycan tune products
and then see where that gets you and
then you'll know if if maybe you pick a
day you pick even days for transition
you have maybe two conditions day 10 and
a 12
you need a glidecam profile somewhere in
between that then you narrow down based
on that experiment where you could pick
a transition on day 11 to kind of really
target that specific like AM profile
wonderful thank you we have some great
questions coming in from our
participants
here's another what do I do if I want to
get let go okay so that's the g0 Pig so
that would be in this case what I showed
was you can certainly start with just
the media and the efficient feed plus
products because there aren't like
oscillation modulating components in
either one of those you'll get a high g0
peak I know that there are situations
where maybe a customer's using a a media
and feed of their choosing that maybe
have components in it that do shift
glycans in that case that's a little
harder to work with
if it
it's a feat of their own and certainly
that's an opportunity for a services
project where we can modify that
formulation so that they don't get as
much clock oscillation but I think you
know in the examples that I showed the
only way to to get to that higher G 0 G
0 F level would be to not use the big
like interim products or make a
transition later in culture so you're
not feeding as much of those
glycosylated enhancing components
throughout throughout the the run of the
experiment that way you'll see higher G
0 right thank you so much here's our
last question from our audience members
my media alone pushes to the limit too
far what can I do
again that's that's a that's a case
where you know if if that's a
commercially available media from
somebody other than thermo Fisher I
don't know how much we could do with
that but if it's a a custom media or
something that a customer is using and
they have that formulation they know
what that formulation is and they're
willing to share that formulation with
our services group that we can go ahead
and run those DOA experiments and small
reactor studies to to test what kind of
levels of some of these components would
would get them to the right glidecam
profile or kind of back that off a bit
so that it's not pushed too far I think
we've got another question that came in
too
I I think so too um here's another one
can glycol tune be used in research
applications or specifically for bio
production yeah
it could be used in any situation really
in my case I'm using it and more of a
small scale flasks small scale by
reactors maybe half liter reactors and
it certainly works in that that
environment quite well again it you know
obviously that that can easily scale up
to much larger sizes and I know it works
at larger sizes and I showed examples
using Cho DZ 44 cells but there's no
reason that that this couldn't be tried
with other cell types again 293 cells
maybe a cell line of your choosing that
that you want to get a better
glycosylated profile so yes you know
that the product is sold at as low as a
1 liter pack size so certainly we can
you know a customer could purchase that
and try that at a research scale at
whatever size they deem necessary
great thank you thank you again Ryan
Boniface for your present
nation I'd also like to take the
opportunity to think lab roots and get
Co part of thermo Fisher Scientific for
making today's educational webcast
possible audience members additional
questions will be answered and published
on Thermo Fisher Scientific website you
will receive an email notification when
answers are available before you go just
reminder to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through April 2018
you'll receive an email from lab reach
let you know when that webcast will be
available for replay please share this
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event enjoy
the rest of the virtual conference
that's all for now thanks for joining us
we'll see you soon goodbye
you